(intense music buildup)
- It's keto time!
(techno intro music)
Keto, Keto, Keto. I challenged you
to get my keto video to
twenty thousand likes
and you surpassed that goal plenty.
And I'm actually really
excited about this.
I'm unfortunately fresh out of a break up
so I'm more motivated than ever
to change my lifestyle
around, be healthier,
look better, I wanna take you guys
along for that journey.
My one month of keto starts now.
(intense orchestral music)
- Just do it!
All right, I'm gonna have
my very first keto meal.
It's the middle of the day,
I didn't have breakfast
so I guess you could say I'm
intermittent fasting today as well.
This is my meal here, beef
chili with oaxaca cheese?
Oaxaca? And cauliflower rice.
To my surprise, the first few days of keto
weren't that bad. I was
totally expecting that
I would go with keto flu
symptoms right off the bat.
It wasn't that bad, I didn't
have sugar withdrawal.
The weight stayed the same,
my strength was there,
but I'd fatigue much earlier in my sets.
Can't even be certain it's
to do with the keto diet,
but that's what was happening.
All right, my man just shot a shot,
made me drop my phone.
This guy right here, wanna
be basketball player.
All right, today's my first day of cardio
with keto on board and I gotta admit,
I'm feeling pretty tired.
I just beat both of these guys though.
I was able to keep up with
them, my sprints were fine,
my game was fine, but I noticed
that after a game or two,
when I would be somewhat out of breath,
I was totally burnt. I was really tired,
much more than usual.
Again, not certain that it's 100 percent
due to the keto diet,
but I do suspect keto
is playing a role in my
decreased stamina in my exercise.
The keto struggle is so real,
I'm eating cat food.
- Let me at least fix my
hair a make sure I look good.
- While Lisa's eating a healthy
salad with some croutons.
- I'm eating cat food.
Tell them about the cat food.
- [Lisa] It's salmon!
- What damn cat food?
- He's eating cat food, it's right there.
- That's called the keto struggle.
Going into the second week of keto,
I was starting to struggle a lot
with my food choices.
When I go to work, and I'm
gonna be working a long shift,
I can't bring all of
these goodies, an avocado,
and all this stuff.
So, what did I do?
I brought a Thrive Market can of salmon,
with some mayonnaise and
I basically ate cat food.
Eating a diet that's so high in fat,
I mean 75 percent of
my calories were coming
from fat, it's difficult
to maintain that and I don't plan well.
For example, if I'm going to a big event,
I should probably eat beforehand.
You have to plan ahead if
you wanna stick to keto.
Because when you go to a fast food joint,
or a restaurant, yes they
may have a piece of meat,
but eating high protein is not keto.
You have to be eating high fat.
So you have to be thinking about what
it is you're gonna choose off the menu.
And you can get a cheeseburger
that's very fatty,
has sauce on it that's
hopefully carb free,
that's not optimal keto.
That's the dirty keto
that people talk about.
If you're eating high saturated
fats, over cooked red meats,
using processed oils, that's
not something I generally
recommend or want for myself.
Wait!
(police sirens)
Two weeks in, I already
had some results showing.
My clothes were fitting
better, my abs were
coming out of hibernation,
like one of them
legit came out and said, "What up!"
And I was like, "Oh my god look its my ab,
I used to see you back in the day
and then you started hibernating."
It did surprise me that after two weeks
of keto, I was already
starting to see results
and now I get why this diet is so popular
amongst people who are trying
to lose weight quickly.
And not that I'm advocating for that,
but it was nice to see
results so early on,
and quite motivational.
I will say though, the
majority of the weight loss
that happens in the first week
or so is usually water weight.
That's not gonna be sustainable,
that speed of weight loss.
I feel like on keto, I
wake up really hungry.
Normally I don't mind skipping breakfast,
but on keto I'm starving.
It's probably because I'm eating
so much less calories than usual.
Getting into the later weeks of keto,
I was getting hungry.
That doesn't mean I wasn't satiated,
I mean eating a lot of
fats, you get full quickly
and you're no longer hungry.
But when I say hungry, I
mean more like cravings.
Bananas, cookies and cream milkshakes,
and then I even noticed a
pattern where I was hungry,
just because I was bored.
I had a high fat meal, I had
some sardines with guacamole.
I'm full. But I wanna munch on something,
I just wanna eat some chips,
so I've realized that I like to bored eat.
And on keto, you really can't bored eat.
Unless you just eat nuts all day,
I don't understand how many almonds
you can eat in one day before you.
I think I broke keto.
I mean not technically, but I had several
drinks last night that technically
throws you out of keto.
They were not sugary
drinks, I just had soda
and alcohol but that does technically
take you out of ketosis at
least for a short while so
you probably think I'm a failure.
Look, we all make mistakes
and two steps forward
with one step back, is
still one step forward.
That's something that
I want you to remember
and take away from my keto journey.
If you mess up, it's not
the end of the world.
It's doesn't mean that you're a failure.
Yes, I had a few drinks
and it took me out of
ketosis for a little bit
because your body actually metabolizes
the alcohol and uses that
as energy instead of fats.
But, it's fine. As soon
as I stopped drinking
the alcohol, the next
day I was probably back
in ketosis and everything
was back on track.
So did it slow down my progress?
Probably somewhat, but it
wasn't the end of the world.
If I treated it like it
was the end of the world,
that would hurt my progress because
that would demotivate me, and cause me
to order some cookies and cream milkshakes
and we know we can't do that on keto.
I had a renewed determination
to continue and finish my keto journey.
(upbeat music)
One month of keto is in the books!
I made it, I ate 75 percent
of my calories from fat,
20 percent from protein,
5 percent from carbs.
I stuck to this bad boy.
But let's talk summary, let's
talk about what happened.
First and foremost, body.
I started this diet at 208 pounds,
I weighed in this morning at 202 pounds.
So that's a six pound
weight loss in 4 weeks,
sounds pretty appropriate, about a pound
and a half per week.
My abs are showing a little bit more,
which gets me really excited for summer.
Now when it comes to my mind, I don't
necessarily feel any big
difference that jumps out.
But I do notice that
I don't crash as much,
especially in the midday section.
(upbeat music)
For the average healthy
person going on a short
course of keto will help
them lose some weight
and it probably won't be
detrimental to their health.
If you're gonna start a new
diet, any diet for that matter,
go see your doctor and
have that conversation.
Figure out what are the
benefits versus harms
so you can make the most educated decision
possible moving forward.
I hope you guys enjoyed
me trying out keto,
if you want me to continue
trying out weird things,
diets, whatever, drop it
down below in the comments
and smash that like button
and if you tried keto
and you had an experience of your own,
also jump into the comments section
as you know, I'm very active down there.
And if you wanna see more
about my take on diets,
click here for my playlist and as always,
stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat techno music)